So in the two examples that we just looked at, there was a vast space of inputs
and some small part of that constituted the actual input domain for the software under test.
And what happened was when we generated invalid inputs, which was extremely easy to do,
they were executing a boring part of the software under test
and getting them out to input rejection errors.
And those rejections of invalid input were basically forcing us to generate another value
and submit it and see what happens.
So what's going to happen is the random testing loop is going to spend a lot of time spinning.
That is to say, stressing on only a small part of the software under test.
But there's actually something different that can happen that's much worse than that.
So the other thing that can happen is the input isn't rejected.
And the reason that an invalid input might not be rejected is
that the software under test failed to contain sufficient validity checking logic
in order to distinguish valid inputs from invalid inputs.
And so what we're getting now is something potentially much worse.
We get strange misbehavior, crashes, or something else very bad.
And the problem is that when we get misbehavior, crashes, and other bad behavior
from the software under test, these behaviors instead of being rejected by the software under test
and letting our random testing loop proceed, these behaviors look like bugs.
So normally if we crash the software under test, this is something that we have to track down manually
and now we're taking a developer's time.
And once we start taking human's time, what we're essentially doing is mounting
a denial of service attack on whoever is processing bugs that come out of the random testing loop
after looking at about 10 bugs that are caused by invalid inputs to the software under test
the person who is looking at that input is going to get tired of it
and isn't going to look at them any more and now we have a problem.
Now we have a random testing loop producing no actionable output.
And so our random testing effort has basically failed.
And so let's talk a little bit about why software under test would lack a validity checker.
Well, as we saw I believe in Unit 1, internal interfaces, that is to say interfaces within a product
and interfaces that don't spend trust boundaries often lack full validity checking.
And they do that for performance reasons for code maintainability reasons
basically because we have to trust somebody sometimes.
Otherwise, we can't get a new software written.
Another reason is, there exists software for which it is impossible to construct a validity checker.
And so earlier in this unit, I was talking about the example of using Csmith.
That is to say, my random test generator that generate C programs for testing compilers
and it turns out that C compilers don't contain a good validity checker for C.
And the reasons for that are kind of involved but the quick answer is that
if you have a C program it's undecidable whether that program dereferences a null pointer,
accesses an out-of-bounds array element, or do something else that violates the rules of C.
So compilers do do quite a lot of validity checking--
that is to say, they look for syntactically invalidacy.
What they fail to do is check for the dynamic validity properties that are required
for certain kinds of miscompilation books.
So in summary, the input validity problem bites us as a performance problem
almost every time we write a random tester.
It bites us in a much more serious way when we have some software under test
that lacks a reliable validity checker.